[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARLOS DE LA TORRE: My
name is Carlos de la Torre,
and I am a [? BCTN ?] scholar
with the Malaysia Sustainable
Cities Program, a joint
MIT-UTM initiative.
I am a former revenue advisor
with the State Government
of Madhya Pradesh, India
and with the Ministries
of Finance of Cambodia
and Indonesia.
During this video, I would
like to talk to you about how
a complimentary
bottom-up approach may
improve the rate of
success in energy subsidy
reform in Malaysia.
First, let me give you some
background on energy subsidies
and subsidy reform
initiatives in Malaysia.
Authorities have adopted
fossil fuel energy subsidies
to provide temporary
or permanent buffer
against changes in
international oil prices,
support a state-owned
energy companies
as a component of
industrial policy,
and provide access to energy
services to low income groups.
Over time, authorities
have realized
that energy subsidies have
several unintended consequences
and costs.
Energy subsidies
have been associated
with fiscal imbalances,
displaced priority [INAUDIBLE]
spending, and overspending
in road infrastructure,
excessive energy consumption,
and under-investment
in existing electric utilities
and in renewable energy,
degradation of
local air quality.
An inequity of
subsidies are captured
by higher income households.
In Malaysia, the cost
of energy subsidies
have been estimated at 6% of
GDP, or $24.2 billion in 2015.
The estimate would
be conservative,
if it excludes, for example, tax
incentives and government loan
guarantees to the fossil
fuel industry in Malaysia.
In order to reform
energy subsidies,
authorities have used
executive orders alone,
or executive orders followed by
legislative budget approvals.
This process in both a limited
number of key stakeholders,
such as the Ministry of Finance
and high-ranking executive
branch officials.
The measures were
developed with the belief
that this approach was faster
and the information at hand
was reliable enough.
Unfortunately, the
absence of support
by key stakeholders
for subsidy reform
reflects a lack of confidence
in the ability of governments
to reallocate the
resulting budgetary savings
to the next best alternative
for the overall benefit
of the population, concerns
that vulnerable groups would not
be protected, and an
understanding that subsidies
are a mechanism to
distribute the benefits
of natural resource
endowments to the population
in the absence of
targeted social programs.
Depending on the
context, authorities
can develop a series
of simple steps
to incorporate a complimentary
bottom-up approach
to the prevailing
top-down approach,
so as to improve the
likelihood of success
in an energy subsidy reform.
In the first step,
authorities need
to identify key stakeholders and
how they relate to each other.
Taking the case of electricity
tariff reform in Malaysia,
authorities can identify
as key stakeholders
the state-owned oil and gas
company providing gas inputs
to the system, the
Minister of Finance,
the Prime Minister's office,
the consumers of electricity
services, and the
environment, represented
by the Ministry of
the Environment,
and environmental
groups, or both.
In the second step,
authorities need
to assess the performance
of the stakeholders
and society as a whole.
Taking the case of electricity
tariff reform in Malaysia,
authorities realize
that energy subsidies
have led to more energy
consumption, lower government
revenues, and potentially
more local air pollution.
In step three, once key
issues are identified
and rules for respectful
exchange and problem solving
are agreed upon, key
stakeholders and authorities
can begin to consider
alternatives.
Taking the case of electricity
tariff reform in Malaysia,
stakeholders and
authorities can consider
alternatives incorporating
changes in tariff levels,
changes in tax incentives
that will affect
the cost of capital, a cash
transfer program for low income
families, or a combination.
Each alternative will
represent a different position
for each stakeholder and
for the society as a whole.
Two or three
alternatives are then
selected for a final evaluation
against commonly agreed
criteria.
In the final step, authorities
and key stakeholders
select the alternative that
accommodates their interest.
Taking the case of electricity
tariff reform in Malaysia,
authorities and
stakeholders select
the package of tariff rate, tax
incentive, and cash transfer
program measures that
meet their interests,
and the selection criteria.
Now, the selected package can
incorporate into the budget
process as a budget proposal.
In summary, a complimentary
bottom-up approach
helps generate more information,
capacity, and trust,
to implement subsidy reforms.
This approach, alongside
a top-down one,
should improve the rate of
success of energy subsidy
reforms.
In this presentation,
we have used
the case of electricity
tariff reform in Malaysia
to explain in detail
the steps suggested.
However, the same
steps can be tailored
to the different contexts
faced by authorities
in other countries.
[MUSIC PLAYING]